[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal as
d'informations locales nous sommes le
mercredi 22 décembre voici les titres de
cette édition
ils sont impactés par la crise sanitaire
depuis presque deux ans où on est la
fréquentation des lieux culturels
aujourd'hui les modes de consommation ou
encore les habitudes des yvelinois
ont-ils changé les explications dans ce
journal un concours de tir à l'arc s'est
tenue à guyancourt ce week end cent
soixante dix archers étaient au
rendez-vous de cette compétition
yvelinoise par milieu julien l'allemand
aride et premier de sa catégorie son
portrait dans cette édition est plus
réduit tombée place à la féerie de noël
pour les fêtes de fin d'année les
maisons se sont parés de leurs plus
belles décorations nous vous ferons
découvrir les illuminations des
yvelinois
[Musique]
coup d'envoi de la vaccination pour les
enfants de 5 à 11 ans depuis ce matin
ils ont désormais la possibilité
d'obtenir une première dose sur la base
du volontariat les enfants à risque où
vivent avec des personnes porteuses de
comorbidité ont la priorité aux
vaccinodromes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les premiers
enfants accompagnés de leurs parents ont
sauté le pas puis les réserver et
vaccins en 2002 aménagé par pfizer jean
michel fourgous président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines nous en dit plus au micro de
céline charles il faut d'abord avoir un
entretien approfondi avec eux il faut
leur faire un petit
sur le volet un peu de temps pour tout
de suite voir s'ils n'ont pas déjà
ensuite il faut un entretien de pour les
rassurer pour dédramatiser un peu la
situation donc là on entre les médecins
mais sur beaucoup plus de temps il y il
ose un autre discours bien sûr ensuite
il faut une autre une aiguille plus
petit il faut un demi dose
[Musique]
à 2021 représente encore une fois une
année compliquée pour la culture les
salles de spectacle et les cinémas
dresse un bilan mitigé malgré et ont
raison de la pandémie elle fermeture
baisse de fréquentation mais également
sans mouvement des habitudes et des
explications dans ce reportage de
patrick jacques de dixmude et matt
ile-de-france depuis la reprise de la
saison culturelle en septembre les
salles de spectacles constate une baisse
de fréquentation mais également des
changements d'habitude les abonnements
se font rares les spectateurs achètent
leur place au dernier moment où paye
mais ne se présente pas c'est fragile on
regarde les gens reviennent pour les
têtes d'affiché ça ça fonctionne mais
les gens n'achètent plus haut comme
auparavant avec un abonnement on a pu
d'abonnés c'est très rare
voilà c'est ce contrat d'une main les
gens achètent vraiment au dernier moment
puisqu'ils attendent vraiment et je
pense que répéter ce qui s'est passé
auparavant ils ont peur de se retrouver
avec des places
sur les bras si tu as la fermeture des
boîtes de nuit le 10 décembre et face à
la montée des cas du variant au micron
les directeurs du théâtre de la mairie
se montre inquiet ce qui nous inquiète
ce que on a commencé donc
avec cette dernière vague avec la
fermeture des discothèques après le
cotec voilà c'est quoi c'est soit un
couvre-feu sur la fermeture des lieux
culturels même son de cloche du côté des
cinémas malgré une programmation riche
les salles sont loin d'avoir retrouvé
leur niveau de fréquentation d'avant la
crise sanitaire -30% par rapport à 2019
des chiffres en baisse avait quand même
constat les habitudes ont changé je
pense que les gens ont pris aussi
d'autres habitudes on parle beaucoup du
streaming des plateformes et cetera oui
je pense qu'effectivement il ya de ça
c'est sûr mais les cinémas peuvent tout
de même compter sur les blockbuster
marvel le dernier liederman sortie le 15
décembre a réalisé le meilleur démarrage
de l'année avec 476 me landry en france
dès le premier jour on a eu une semaine
comme je te le disais complètement folle
avec spider man qui est le succès de
l'année le blockbuster que tout le monde
veut voir donc là retour des gens en
masse dans les salles comme si s'était
rien passé absolument c'est vrai une
année assez compliqué pour les lieux
culturels qui espère rester ouverts
l'année prochaine la mairie a déjà
programmé ses têtes d'affiché comme tryo
ou coeur de pirate et les cinémas
peuvent encore compter sur la sortie du
prochain batman ce crime ou encore les
animaux fantastiques
et on l'a dit est les lieux culturels
sont impactés par la crise sanitaire
depuis presque deux ans et pour
approfondir ce sujet sur la
fréquentation fait le point avec vous et
l'audi carnis bonjour bonjour vous êtes
la directrice du musée rangoly train de
rambouillet on vient d'avoir l'exemple
des cinémas théâtres est ce que pour les
musées c'est pareil s'ils sont aussi
touchés alors nous ça se passe plutôt
bien on a on voit que les gens vraiment
envie de repartir et venir chez nous
donc non nous on a eu un très bon été là
le l'automne a été bon là c'est plus
calme depuis début décembre mais c'est
normal et avant noël et les gens font ou
la france mais là on va partir
d'aujourd'hui ça repart puisqu'on est
conclue aujourd'hui
et est ce que justement la fréquentation
reste quand même en baisse par rapport à
2019 avant la crise sanitaire où
finalement on revient à l'avant qu'ovide
pour les vacances de toussaint en cause
des jaugeurs on avait moins
fréquentation puisque on n'accueille que
30 personnes à peu près par heure ça
fait à peu près cent trente personnes
par jour alors qu'avant une colline où
on n'est qu'à 3 donc là c'est pas une
question de peur du virus c'est plus une
question en fait de joe gens c'est ça
oui parce qu'on refuse en fait qu'au vu
des gens on l'obligé
est ce que vous avez observé une
évolution je pense aux pratiques des
yvelinois en conséquence de cette crise
sanitaire par exemple moins de
réservations en amont plus de dernière
minute
là oui vraiment pendant ses vacances je
pense qu'avec le la relance du virus les
gens étaient vraiment au jour le jour
pour que vos dernières vacances qu'on
avait vraiment fait des comptes les
quelques jours auparavant alors que là
ça fait rentrer vraiment dans la matinée
et comment s'adapter ce que vous avez dû
vous adapté par rapport à ce qui est
présenté dans le musée où par rapport
justement à ces nouveaux modes
finalement ces nouvelles habitudes
avant ce qui est dommage c'est qu'avant
pendant l'éveil les petites vacances
quand vous êtes toujours une animation
qui était accessible à tous mais là les
crayons et temps d'une heure maximum
pour pouvoir accueillir le plus grand
nombre en bleu plus pour poser cette
petite animation donc effectivement on
propose autre chose on a mis en place
une
application de visite avec avec jurés
convaincus qu'ils s'appellent and media
il faut retrouver la mémoire du lieu qui
a été perdu grâce à une petite sorcière
et avec qui je donc on a en a remplacé
comme sa maman et du coup pour ce qui
est de la fréquentation comment vous le
sentez un peu pour les vacances de noël
ou même le début d'année à venir
plus de biens par un mot pour nous ça
parle ça reparte damman même les groupes
un qui était absent depuis mi-mars là on
a vraiment des classes qui reviennent il
ya beaucoup de demandes non c'est plutôt
là donc plutôt positif c'est pour
repenser l'ensemble des musées où c'est
vraiment propre à au musée rimbaud
litres un nom je peux maintenant ce que
j'entends autour de moi ça l'a plutôt de
repartir dans les milieux outils
vous êtes un peu moins impactés on va
dire que que le reste c'est en tout cas
que d'autres lieux culturels
peut-être vu qu'on est pendant les
vacances de noël avant de vous laisser
quelles sont les animations à venir
finalement pour les vacances de noël ou
pour ce début d'année alors là pour les
vacances de noël on propose des journées
avec vitre un jardin quand on a pu voir
sur les images la france sauf que on l'a
décoré le jardin ou couleurs de noël
avec les gars noël avec des petits
gnomes et ont des petits cadeaux c'est
vraiment le circuit sympa du père noël
de train du père noël donc ça c'est
aujourd'hui et mercredi prochain afin
que le train est accessible que avec la
réservation de la visite du mil et le
vendredi matin pour attendre le père
noël on l'a on propose une visite
spéciale jeune public
avec le petit train et le voyage du père
noël ont pour les 3 à 8 ans à peu près
et après ça va être à la rentrée
on ferme deux semaines par contre après
les vacances scolaires pour pouvoir
installer des nouvelles choses dedans
lisez et après les partis c'est marthe 9
janvier on aura les babys visite qui
vont commencer les babys visite c'est
pour les enfants de 18 mois à 3 ans
passés le mercredi et le samedi matin
dont 26 et 29 janvier sur thème des
marchandises il ya un thème différent
tous les oies et à 16h15 c'est pour les
un peu plus grand pour les maternelles
de trois incidents voilà ça sera sur le
thème des les goûts il y aura deux
séances
la première le 26 janvier et la
prochaine en mars et par rapport aux
lego et on les lit me suis un peu
reportage
c'est bien donc ça c'est noter et c'est
par rapport aux jo j'imagine qu'il faut
vous disiez peut-être réserver en amont
sur le site
mais soudain fait le mieux c'est de
réserver parce que si vous venez d'en
avoir et arrive n'est pas sûr de pouvoir
rentrer à leurs amis et on peut faire ça
sur le site
j'imagine ou par téléphone au 1 800
points comme
ramsar vous voyez en temps réel les
rennais en bâtiment et la place c'est
noté merci beaucoup elodie carnis
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle vous
êtes la directrice justement du musée
rend poli train de rambouillet merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
et durant tout le mois de décembre
l'association ressource et vous a mis en
place une ressourcerie éphémère à
attrape financé par le bailleur icf
habitat le but était d'être présent au
plus près des habitants l'objectif
sensibiliser à la réduction des déchets
et au développement d'éco gestes le
reportage de mathilde frank ou regarder
des livres des dvd des jouets des
vêtements et même du mobilier on trouve
de tout à la ressourcerie éphémère
installé dans les quartiers des
résidences louise michel à trappes le
but donner une seconde vie à des objets
et sensibiliser les habitants à une
consommation plus responsable pour la
planète
l'idée c'est vraiment de mettre en place
cette ce concept de ressourcerie
éphémère au plus des habitants et venir
sensibiliser les personnes aux plus
proches de chez elle est du coup donné
ses solutions qu'on peut avoir de
réemploi et de réutilisation des objets
et d'arrêter de jeter des objets ce que
ça peut servir à quelqu'un face à
l'augmentation des dépôts sauvages sur
la voie publique et dans les parties
communes ressourcez-vous et le bailleur
social et fc habitat ont mis en place un
partenariat pour être au plus près des
habitants ce jour-là un atelier dup
cycling est organisée pour relooker et
réemployés du petit mobilier locke
cycling alors c'est le détournement
d'objets par le biais de deux
différentes fonctions c'est soit
détourné son utilité donc par exemple
une chaise devient une étagère par
exemple tout en la réinventant avec
d'autres coloris valoriser revendre mais
aussi collecter des objets qui ont déjà
servi et dont on ne veut plus le
principe donner à la place de jeter
depuis le temps que j'en tasset en me
demandant
ce que j'allais en faire mais surtout
pas jeter là
'l'annonce d'un d'une ressourcerie
éphémère à trappes a été la bienvenue
pour pouvoir me débarrasser de tout ce
qui traînait et qui peut resservir mais
plus pas moi cette opération s'est
terminé le 18 décembre et a permis de
collecter une tonnes d'objets
et côté sport à présent à guyancourt
chaque année un concours de tir à l'arc
est organisée par le club guyancourt toi
pour l'occasion il a eu lieu ce week end
170 archers se sont réunis parmi eux
julien l'allemand un des meilleurs sur
ce tournoi retour sur sa performance
avec célia gâte son goût regarder
une bonne dose de concentration en plein
dans le mille julien allemand vient
d'enchaîner trois volets à 10 points une
performance assez dur à réaliser ces
raisons xining alors les uns à la suite
sur la même volée et puis leur répéter
volée après volée c'est là où c'est le
plus compliqué
ça fait du bien de calais 3 10 comme
chaque année cet habitant de la marne
participent au concours de tir à l'arc
de guyancourt environ 170 archers sont
présents au gymnase maurice baquet
adhérents du club puis en courtois
pendant trois ans julien allemand
revient uniquement dans les yvelines
pour cette compétition cela fait 25 ans
qu'il pratique ce sport il y trouve de
nombreux avantages la recherche de
performance le côté convivial qui peut y
avoir aussi et puis ça m'apporte
beaucoup sur le plan personnel
c'est un sport assez complet ça me fait
ça fait vraiment du bien de pouvoir tir
à l'arc julien l'allemand est l'un des
meilleurs archers de cette compétition
yvelinoise il a gagné trois fois le
tournoi européen des cinq nations en
2004 2005 et 2017
si je me trompe pas
j'ai aussi fait d'autres tournois
internationaux en france en belgique en
hollande
en allemagne ou au royaume uni tous
n'ont donc pas le même niveau mais
qu'importe ce week end le concours
s'achève par des finales les 16
meilleurs de chaque catégorie
s'affrontent ça permet de faire un
entraînement pour tous les archers que
j'ai ça leur permet de s'entraîner pour
les championnats de france où c'est les
mêmes formules où ils auront avec des
duels à élimination directe cette fois
ci je suis l'un allemand a terminé
premier de sa catégorie arc à poulies de
quoi le rassurer en vue d'autres
compétitions
depuis quelques semaines et pour les
fêtes de fin d'année les maisons se sont
parés à de guirlandes rennes ou encore
un bonhomme de neige à quelques jours de
noël mathilde francou a vendu visite à
une mini montaise elle est habituée à
depuis plusieurs années à la mise en
place de ces illuminations regarder
[Musique]
à la nuit tombée les maisons de la rue
de l'ancienne mairie à montigny le
bretonneux s'illuminent pour laisser
place à la féerie de noël une licorne
des champignons ou encore des pingouins
venue du pôle nord qui est venu sandrine
est ravi de partager ses décorations
avec les passants gros bonhommes de
neige que vous pouvez voir avec ces
petits flocons ensuite on passe par un
petit passage nous avons la famille de
serre le papa et la maman et son bébé
des décorations qui représente tout de
même un budget conséquent d'un budget
rennes c'est 150 euros à peu près le
bonhomme de neige aussi
oui je l'avais eue cherifi en 50 % je
les avais acheté après les après les
décorations faites quand y sol de tous
et la décoration de lidl 8 euros et
chaque année sandrine enrichit un peu
plus sa collection le but est également
d'illuminer le visage des enfants qui
passent devant sa maison se trouve que
c'est plus gai et en plus comme on
habite juste en face l'école ma les
enfants ça leur permet de d'égayer un
peu leur fin d'année qui avec cette
année hugo vide un peu compliqué je
trouve que c'est un peu de joie dans ce
monde un peu compliqué à 48 heures de
noël les passants de la rue de
l'ancienne mairie peuvent encore
patienter en lumière avant de retrouver
leurs cadeaux au pied du sapin
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver mélanie poquet à la
présentation de votre 7,8 société très
bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]